hello and welcome to this evening's
reconvened meeting of planning and
development management committee just to
introduce myself my name is adam
williams and i serve as the chair of the
committee
also present on this call are the
committee vice chair
for ben hartley officers from the
council's planning service
legal and democratic services local
highway authority
as well as elected councillors who make
the voting month to the committee
and before we turn to the business of
the meeting i should just advise
reference
information that this meeting has been
live streamed and recorded so please
mute your microphones to minimize
background noise
if you wish to speak on an item please
use the chat facility
facility to notify me and then wait
until you were called to speak
um just for the purposes of recording i
didn't know if any members had any uh
interest that they wanted to declare i
appreciate that were declared last
week as well um just the willows primary
school my child goes there so
um but hopefully you'll do that mata
when i've when i've um probably left the
meeting by then
thank you thank you um so
we'll turn left at the applications for
consideration this evening the first
application that we'll consider actually
relates to two separate
items on the agenda and those both being
both concerning waitrose food store
indoor teeth and you can find them on
pages 45 and 97 of the committee report
and
they're going to be introduced as one
but voted on separately and i think mr
dave is
going to introduce that and explain why
yeah thank you chair um i think ms coley
is just going to
upload the screen slideshow
um yeah um
okay so these two applications relate to
the waitrose supermarket in ultrahim
the site is occupied by a large
supermarket with several smaller
commercial units attached
the area surrounding the site is
primarily residential in nature
planning application 868719 granted
planning permission for the development
of the site as a local center which
included the waiter's supermarket
and condition seven of that permission
restricts the hours of deliveries to the
site to between 0-700
to 2100 on any day the current
application 101
seeks to vary that condition to allow
for deliveries to the site to take place
between
700 and 200 on any day
for a temporary one year period so
that's one additional hour in the
evening
the other application 102.090 seeks to
vary condition 5
of planning permission 99647
which granted permission for an
extension to the waiter's
warehouse primarily to facilitate an
expansion of the online delivery
part of the business condition five also
restricts the hours
to between 700 and 2100
on any day and it's the application
seeks to
vary that permission to allow deliveries
to the site and home deliveries from the
site to take place between
700 and 200 on any day ensuring that the
two conditions
on the two permissions would remain
consistent
um so looking at the plan there you can
see that the service yard is at the
northern end
of the site with the access off draybank
road
to the west and with residential
properties on the on the other side of
drybank road
facing that access um
the two red edged application sites are
different but both
applications actually relate to the same
access and service yard
so the main difference between them is
simply that the condition on the second
application
related to home deliveries online
deliveries whilst the first condition
didn't actually cover that
so the primary consideration with both
applications is the impact that extended
delivery hours
would have on the residential amenity of
neighbouring occupiers
delivery vehicles must pass a number of
residential properties on draybank road
um with the access a short distance away
from residential properties to the north
on vetchwood gardens as well
twelve letters of objection have been
received in relation to application 101
748
and three letters of objection in
relation to the other application
objectives make reference to disturbance
associated with the movement of delivery
vehicles as well as their loading and
unloading
the objections also made reference to
deliveries currently being made outside
of the committed hours
the applicant has clarified that this is
due
to the site operating under the
provisions of a written ministerial
statement
which has had the effect of relaxing
planning restrictions on delivery hours
during the kobe 19
pandemic
sorry i just lost the screen for a
minute um
as set out in the additional information
report the applicant has submitted noise
management plans in respect to each
application
which set out measures to reduce noise
at the site to acceptable levels
these include a provision ensuring that
plans can be updated
in response to issues raised by the
local planning authority
the council's environmental health
officers have confirmed that the noise
management plans are acceptable
and officers consider that the
implementation of the noise management
plans would be appropriate mitigation
for the additional hour of deliveries in
the evening furthermore
the temporary nature of the permissions
would allow the operation of the site to
be monitored
during the period of the consent and any
disturbance complaints to be considered
should a permanent permission be sought
in the future
on this basis the proposals are
considered to comply with policy l7 of
the court strategy
with regard to the protection of
residential immunity and so are
recommended for approval
thank you chair um thank you mr day
i understand that there's been a
representation received from
uh mr moyle who is objecting to
permission being granted in his
statements to be read out
yes chair i will read out the statement
on behalf
of liam royal a resident of draybank
road and he is the objection relates to
both applications
his comments are as follows i live at
the end of draybank road in the
apartments
the impact the large wagons have on my
day-to-day life
isn't a tremendous one however on an
evening the noise these wagons generate
is more than loud enough to halt a
conversation or drown out the tv
with my current job i am required to
start relatively early and as such tend
to go to sleep
at around half past eight nine o'clock
at night
during the height of the pandemic when
deliveries were happening until
2300 hours sometimes i can say for
definite it was having a huge
negative impact on my daily life and
impeding my work and having a negative
effect
on my mental health i raised numerous
complaints of waitrose
which were dealt with extremely well and
the deliveries returned to their agreed
hours soon after
my main concern is that if this returns
i will back to the same situation
thank you
thank you ms milner and i think that we
have
shane stevens speaking in favor of the
application
yeah hi thank you mr stevens um you've
got six minutes to speak and if you do
um
overrun at all i'll just politely
request that you back up your remarks
thank you
great thank you good evening members my
name is shane stevens i'm an operations
manager with the retail risk and
compliance team at waitress and partners
the applications before you are
submitted in order to relax the permit
to delivery hours
for stock replenishment and to expand
the home delivery service
they are submitted following the
council's recent grant of consent for
warehouse extension which was sought to
the express purpose of expanding the
popular
local service at our auction shop
the proposals will allow deliveries to
be made for one additional hour in the
evening
there's no increase proposed to the
total number of deliveries by htvs
with delivery simply being spread out
over a wider period
this will allow the store to operate
more efficiently between 7 am 10 pm
in support of the home delivery
operation local demand from residents
for our home delivery service has
remained high
an extended window will also allow home
deliveries to take place
between the hours of 7 a.m and 10 p.m
each day again this will result in a
modest increase
of a single hour each day as members
will be aware the trend towards online
shopping and demand for supermarket home
deliveries has increased exponentially
over the last few years
this trend has accelerated rapidly as a
result the kodi v19 pandemic where
many elderly and vulnerable customers
have found themselves in a position
where they're required to shield and
therefore cannot shop in the store
this will continue to be the case as the
pandemic in jaws and will likely remain
for
many customers once it passes its peak
nevertheless our physical stores will
continue to be the core of our business
and will allow us to continue serving
the community
providing much needed employment for
local people but as we adapt to meeting
changing customer demand and playing
part in strengthening altering the
economy
this element is crucial in response to
the unprecedented increase in demand
resulting from the pandemic we've
increased the frequency of end
deliveries from the store in accordance
with the written ministerial statement
from the government
this recommends increased flexibility
from local planning authorities to
ensure that food supply is not affected
this however is due to expire at the end
of march and it is therefore critical
that we put our home delivery
service on a firmer footing for the
future
at all our locations across the uk we
strive to ensure that all feasible
robust measures are put into place to
allow the immunity of our neighbours to
be safeguarded
working closely with the council's
environmental health officer we've
jointly devised a servicing delivery
management plan that both parties are
confident
will ensure the store can operate
efficiently whilst also protecting the
immunity of residents
we're happy to agree this plan being
secured by an enforceable planning
condition
in addition we've commissioned a noise
impact assessment by an independent
acoustic consultant to assess the
impacts of delivery noise on the
immunity of local residents
again we're confident this demonstrates
their immediacy will be protected but in
order to fine-tune the delivery and
service management plan
we've agreed with the aha suggestion to
implement an initial temporary one-year
consent
to allow additional monitoring and
improvements to be made to the delivery
and home service operation
we offer this compromise as a
responsible retailer with a genuine
desire to work with councillors and
officers to ensure our business can
flourish during these uncertain times
but in a manner that meets the demands
and expectations of our customers and
neighbours
as such we respectfully request that
members support their office's
recommendation for approval
and grant planning permission thank you
thank you mr stevens and council hartley
i think you've indicated
some questions
thank you chair yes i i do so uh
so the first question is is about the
conditions proposed on the two
applications so
my question really is can we make the
conditions about the hours of delivery
consistent so it seems to be artificial
at the moment that we've got the
original application and then the
further application for the warehouse
and
the the conditions on the original site
didn't cover
um online deliveries
to and from the store uh whereas the
conditions on the
on the second application for the
warehouse do and the conditions
that proposed um this time around seemed
to
keep that distinction and i just
wondered why that was and if essentially
the condition
couldn't be the same for both so
condition number five
on the second application which is on
page 105 sort of covers the whole
scope of operations if you like delivers
to and from the development including
those
associated with online delivery um be
permitted between
700 and 200 but the condition on the
first application is still different so
it's just a query about whether we can
make those consistent uh that that's
my first question don't worry to go on
and cover the second question as well
yeah and then and then we can get advice
on both so but the second question was
about assessing the impact
of these permissions so it's because
both applications are given a 12-month
temporary permission
in order to be able to assess the impact
on
residents but what i don't understand
i'm afraid is that
there's a the written ministerial
directions in place that's referred to
in the reports which basically
allows deliveries outside of whatever
hours are
provided for by the conditions so
um whilst that statement's in force
essentially deliveries could occur any
time of day or night as i understand it
so really it's how can we how can we
assess the impact
of these 12-month permissions
whilst that ministerial statement is in
place because deliveries could occur at
any time
anyway so it's really you know do we
know when that
ministerial statement will come to an
end because it seems that it's only from
that point we can really judge the
impact of
these particular uh permissions that are
proposed for 12 months
if that makes sense thank you
yeah i don't know are you confident
responding now mr dave you need a bit of
time
no that's fine i can respond to those um
let's respond to the second one second
question first if that's okay because
that's
probably more straightforward in the um
the written ministerial statement um is
currently due to expire at the end of
march
um it was confirmed on the 29th
of november that it would still remain
in place until the 31st of march
2021 um though
that is due to expire at that point and
therefore
from that point on the conditions um
that there wouldn't be anything else
affecting the conditions
unless there was an announcement that
that was to be extended but there's not
really
any announcement on that to date
um
so the second question um
yeah i think in terms of making the
conditions
consistent in a way it's a bit of an
academic point because
well assuming that the same decision is
made on the two
applications then they would have to
comply with both
conditions um on the two applications
anyway but um
but i suppose i don't see any any reason
in principle why
um the home deliveries um element
couldn't be
included within the other condition
you know i suppose i suppose the fact
was that it wasn't it wasn't mentioned
in that condition originally because it
was
dating from a time when that wasn't
really a major part of the business but
um
uh i don't think there would be any
reason why
that couldn't be any included but but in
a way i think it's a little bit academic
i think they would have to comply with
both them assuming that
the same hours are imposed on both
applications
is that is that clear
yeah thank you yeah that that
is that's really helpful i it just
seemed
a bit academic
if deliveries are only allowed to one
part of the store it's all
so going down the same road and um you
know we'd never be able to sort of
police
whether it's deliveries to or from the
warehouse or the store so um
that's fine thank you that's helpful
thank you a councillor minister
yeah hi um i'm thank you chair i was
just my question was going to be i
i was going to ask about the um
deliveries can it all just be like
consistent with the times but uh council
hardly got that
and the other thing was they've asked
for obviously 12 months
and um obviously the ministerial thing
ends at the end of march so i can
understand why they're trying to
obviously
secure something longer because
otherwise you know what what are they
going to do come
the end of march which is in two weeks
time
so what i was going to what i was going
to ask is also
i have quite a lot of sympathy for the
residents that live nearby
um and i would ima
well i'm quite aware and i hope others
have more than where i'm sure they are
the pandemic is not going to suddenly
end on the 31st of march
so um can we is it possible to change
to not have it as 12 months but have it
as something like
something in between say six or eight or
so months
um so that it allows for the
because where home delivery is going to
still be a a large part
of the business um but then um
that there is still a time that you know
then it gets re-looked at
um because otherwise the ten o'clock is
isn't is quite anti-social really when
you think about
what time people do go to bed to go to
work the next day
and i'm just mindful of the fact that
you know it's not really fair on the on
the people that live nearby
so it's going to ask if we if we can
change a condition at all
if that's something that others um think
see is a good idea or not i think i i
understand where you come from
council in minutes in the sense that
what concerned me when i saw that it
would be a 12-month champion permission
it's just that
if you're a resident who's quite badly
impacted by
um the level of noise nuisance generated
by late night deliveries
then 12 months is actually quite a long
time to have to put up with it so i
suppose
my sort of take on that in the event
that there is real harm calls
to uh to neighboring residents
is there anything that will be done
before the expiry of that 12-month
period or would they just have to
tolerate it for that whole time
that that would be my only slight
concern i suppose
whether you're in a position to support
further
yeah um yeah firstly i i would say that
um one year champion permissions are you
know it's
it's a fairly normal period of time to
grant um
a temporary permission for i suppose the
temperature commission has to be long
enough
to to allow effective monitoring of
whether
whether there is a problem or or not so
um
that is one factor um
but um i suppose our environmental
health officers have
said that they're confident that the
noise management plan will mitigate
um the additional hour but if if there
are any problems
the the plan does um allow for
um the further um review
um of the the elements within that in
the light of any any problems that might
arise so
that can happen during the the period
um during the 12 months
um so
in terms of whether we we could actually
amend the condition i i
i would actually like to just see
whether there's some further advice from
the
uh council solicitors i think that i
think that this was considered
um by the solicitors maybe i don't know
is
could i ask whether there's any any
further comments on that
is ms coburn did you know it wasn't
it wasn't considered by legal
right okay sorry i'm missing any
involvement prior to this
i'm afraid um but
i think it i would
go with your comments that yes it could
be amended
but we have to be sure that that would
give an appropriate
level of um knowledge and monitoring
in order to enable and enable you to get
sort of like true reflection of of the
effects and the impacts on
on neighbours and i would also
add that there are um
statutory nuisance powers that um
the environmental protection um have
that could be
um brought into play if um
if did if it did cause if it did cause a
statutory nuisance
um so the neighbors wouldn't be left
with um
with with the statutory nuisance and no
action being taken
um oh sorry i have on actually
what i was going to say is that i just
feel like that that would be um it's a
lot to put on
the residents that live nearby and i
think that
i understand that normally uh one year
is normal
uh 12 year 12 months sorry is normal
but we're not living in normal times um
quite so
what i'm asking i guess is that i think
that
residents nearby would probably be able
to live with
six months and understand that we still
have a pandemic going on
but i think that when you go to well
it's a 12 month
unless you really really kick up a big
enough stink
basically if it becomes a problem you
have to get enough
going on to actually be able to uh get
it over to
overturned i think is i see that as
being quite unfair to the people that
live nearby
um i'm seeing six months as a happy
medium for
to try and um you know that it's not
that to try and give waitrose
um that the time that they need as well
as the residents aren't then they don't
feel like this is going to go on forever
and so it i mean if others can i can see
what i mean and
agree then can we amend the condition is
that possible
well what i suggest counseling is i
think everyone sort of understands where
you're coming from if we
hear from what what other members
thoughts are on the matter and then we
we can make a collective decision i
suppose and counselor
indicated that speed
um i i think it's um
it is good that a condition of a year
has been set
i do think this would allow for further
review and further understanding of any
problems experienced by the residents
i also think the um the noise management
plan recognizes the complaints of
residents
currently and it does seek to address
them
um and it also
does say in the noise management plan
that though we they'd be putting in an
automated
transport management system or for
hgv drivers to contact the store prior
to our arrival
which um i think will go a long way to
ensuring that your
service yard gates are open in
preparation
it will enable the lorry drivers to
enter the service yard without stopping
and it could be a case that some of the
noise
is minimized um and they'd be able to
pass more smoothly by residential um
properties the the only thing i think
that wasn't
mentioned was whether the transport
management system will stop the
beeping of horns when the lorries enter
but i'd imagine it will it would do
so i think some of the current problems
could be alleviated by the noise
management plan that's being put in
place so that kind of makes me hopeful
but
i do sympathize with residents and i i
do understand how aggravating this type
of noise
pollution can be um but and i think
also that the noise management plan does
rely on
good management of staff um to follow
the set rules
such as careful movement of cages
drivers turning off radios
etc so i think it this plan
will be a big demand on the management
to make sure that these processes
and rules are followed but overall
i think this year period um
is a good thing um and i i think the
management plan
is well written and probably will go
some way to
alleviating some of the problems so i'm
kind of minded to
um agree with off the recommendation at
this point but i do want to hear what
others have to say
thanks chair thank you um councillor
morgan
thank you chair i i'm not going to speak
very long because i'm probably going to
echo what the council of minnesotan
councillor jerome said
but i do have a lot of sympathy um on
this with local residents i've
i've knocked on doors um many
many long time before the pandemic um
hit
and the complaints about noise being and
deliveries at five o'clock in the
morning which i
have read in some of the submissions
from local residents
um really it is echo and sound and sound
like conversations i had
um local residents um the way the
waitrose have to go in and
um i i really i'm i'm probably minded to
support this just because it's under a
year but i really do
hope we really do monitor this noise
management scheme
um because um i mean anyone who's been
to that waitrose knows how close the the
residents are
um to to the entrance um
um i'm quite i'm quite surprised really
for
such a modern supermarket and i really
can see why
if you live close to close to that store
you really are really affected
by everything that store does and and
and the
the supermarket does need to stick to
these rules um and really just need to
monitor them to
because otherwise it is just not
reasonable for residents to be expected
to have noise that goes on well beyond
10 o'clock
thank you jeff
thank you councillor um councillor
jeromey i'd like to make a follow up for
you
yeah i just wanted to add to what
councilman has just said
the environmental officers do we do have
um
a noise app that can be given out to
residents
which is very very easy to use could be
used on people's phones
to allow them to monitor noise um nearby
and also we do do supply diaries which
residents could also use so
it would be good to kind of advise wise
residents beforehand how they they
they could monitor the noise themselves
and kind of
you know be in close contact with
environmental officers as this as this
plan goes on
so i just wanted to add that thanks jeff
yeah
dad understand that council and i think
um
just reflecting on your remarks about
the knowledge management the noise
management plan
and the thing that i found reassuring
about mr royal's
um statement was that he did confirm to
us that when he raised his
um concerns with waitrose originally
that
they did manage to work together to
resolve the problem and eventually there
wasn't as much of an impact from
the deliveries um councilor harley are
you indicating
to speak yes i am although i think
cancer bunting uh did i speak for me so
after
cancer bunting go next thank you uh
councillor
um my point should be very briefing with
the federal meeting
no i haven't that's the point i'm making
i wasn't going to apologize to all
i'm afraid i was delayed from by work
from joining this meeting so it's one to
make a clear
public record that i have as i miss the
beginning of this i will not be taking
part in the debate
and i will be not i will not be casting
any vote in relation to this i just
wanted to come in
and make that point clear before before
we carry on thank you chairman
thank you and councillor hartley
yeah thank you chair i i don't have a
lot to add to what um
councillor jerome and and councillor
morgan have said i mean i think i'm
minded to to accept the officer and
recommendation
to grant i i mean i understand council
amenities
uh concerning point about should it be a
six-month
temporary permission rather than 12
months it's very hard to know
that without knowing the volume of
delivery is going in and out of the site
really
clearly you want a period that um that
will allow you to assess that impact
um once the ministerial statement has
ended
um and you know a low sufficient time to
have a proper impact of
of that extra hour of delivery time
so difficult to know without knowing the
volumes of deliveries but i think i
think 12 months
and given it'll be assessing the impact
of
this permission which is essentially an
extra in the evening then then 12 months
i think is
is probably reasonable in order to make
sure that we can
we can fully assess that impact at the
end of 12 months um
i agree with you and the jerome the
noise management plan seems
pretty comprehensive and and uh pleased
to see waitrose you know responding to
residents complaints
council morgan's right it's a very
difficult site you know the houses are
really close to the um to the to the
supermarket
the only thing that didn't seem to be
covered in the noise management plan a
lot of the focus of it is on the
home delivery vehicles the home delivery
of vans and
you know that they're not left idling
outside
i think some of the concerns from
residents were about lorries
coming in to deliver to the store and
there was a suggestion that they were
arriving early and they were sitting on
the road and leaving their engines
idling
and i i couldn't see that covered in the
noise management plan i might be wrong
but i think you know i don't think that
is enough to refuse permission here i
think i would just
urge that you know that knowledge
management plan is interpreted in a
uh you know a sort of propulsive way i
suppose so that
you know clearly that you know the
people that are
living to or from are going to minimize
noise so i think i think with that in
mind i'd be minded to
agree with the offer officer
recommendation to to grant
and i'm happy to prepare statcha thank
you
thank you um council harley in the
interest of uh
moving business along the scene you know
our second doctor
um if there are any members who would
like to contribute and have not yet done
so
please do just um try and indicate in
the chat but otherwise i think
we've had quite a conversation um
counselor hartley
can you just confirm which application
which application you're proposing now
sorry
yeah i mean i'm happy to prepare us both
but yeah i know when it's here
one at a time so happy to propose the
first one i guess
okay our second emotion uh in favor
of the first one the first one being
that on page 45
the committee report i believe council
yeah i can see you're nodding um no one
else has indicated that they'd like to
speak now so on application 107.48
i'll just move through members as you
appear on the screen and ask you i'd
like to
vote um cancel a minute
um i'll i'll vote to um support
officer recommendation thank you
thank you and councillor hardly
councillor hartley
sorry chair i lost you for a second
happy to uh vote to support the officer
recommendation thank you thank you
councilwood support of the
recommendation
thank you councilwoman stanley
grant and lion got some recommendations
sure thank you thank you councillor
morgan
great to agree with officer
recommendations jeff thank you
um council according to me uh support
officer's recommendation
thank you and councillor dr barclay
support officer recommendation thank you
and i will also be voting to support
officer recommendations that application
is approved
um the second application
um application
on 10209-0 97 of the report i'll propose
that that be
um i'm happy to propose that we accept
off the recommendation that application
i'm wondering if that proposal seconded
thank you counselor um again so we'll
just move to the vote counseling minis
oh i'll wait to support um officer
recommendation thank you thank you
councillor hartley uh support the
officer recommendation thank
thank you councilwood i also support
the recommendation to grant chair thank
you councilman winston
uh support officer recommendations to
ground thank you chair
thank you councillor morgan
vote to agree with officer
recommendations chair
thank you uh council accordingly support
officer's recommendation
thank you and councillor dr berkley
thank you i support officer
recommendation to grant
thank you and i shall also be voting um
support officer recommendations
that application is approved um
next application for consideration this
evening is six robin mode in
ultra income which is on page 56 of the
report
um again this item is going to be
introduced by mr day
yep thank you chair um again i think mrs
coley's just
going to upload this slideshow yeah
yeah so this application is reported to
the planning and development management
committee
due to receiving six objections contrary
to officer recommendation
the application site comprises a
three-storey including the loft
attached dwelling house located to the
northeast of the end of robin road
a small cul-de-sac within altenham the
dwelling has an attached garage to the
northwest side
the property has a relatively short rear
garden that backs onto river brook road
whilst the public footpath runs adjacent
to the rear boundary
the proposal is the direction of a front
porch and part single part three-story
rear extension
as well as a garage conversion and
external alterations
this would create a bedroom with ensuite
and a large kitchen at ground floor
a kitchen at first kitchenette at first
floor and ensuite to the third bedroom
at second floor the applications have
been amended significantly during the
course
during the course of the application
with the admission of a first floor side
extension and a reduction in the scale
height and depth
of the rear extension
the key issues are the impact on the
visuality of the street scene and the
surrounding area
and whether the proposal would cause any
unacceptable overbearing overshadowing
or overlooking impacts
upon neighbouring properties officers
consider that the first development as
amended will result in an
acceptable form of development with
regard to scale
overall appearance and the immunity of
neighbouring
and future residents it's therefore
recommended that the application is
approved subject to conditions
thank you mr day and i believe that we
have
a written statement from dr zhang wing
kai
and against the application yeah
i'll read that out thank you chairman um
report page one proposal failed to
mention the creation of an additional
grease kitchen on the ground floor
and an additional ensuite on the first
floor in total there will be three
kitchens and four ensuite bedrooms after
the extension
page three representations fail to
address
one loss of garden space and two loss of
long hours of sunshine for the adjacent
properties
page five paragraph six this paragraph
uses number four as a reference to
justify that the extension would not
have an over dominant effect on the
adjacent
footpath this is simply misleading the
rear boundary
and the footpath are about five meters
away from number four
whilst being only two meters from the
extended number six
this paragraph also used number four to
justify that the extension is
equal to the street scene this is also
misleading
number four is at the end of the row and
of the original design
the proposed extension procedure in the
middle of the row has a lower roof
and a secondary over the ground floor it
is clearly an afterthought extension
which disturbs the street line
this robe houses in the middle of the
estate and the extension front
central scenery area that is well used
and enjoyed by the community
if this application was granted and all
the houses also be extended similarly
what would this area look like page five
impact on number five robin road many
hours of sunshine from the east
the only quality sunshine number five
gets will be blocked by the multi-story
extension
page six impact on number 7 robin road
overbearing there will only be a 30
centimeter gap between the extended
house and the rear fence
when viewing from our side it will
result in an uncomfortable sense of
enclosure
privacy the first floor window would
have a 100
view of our garden at close proximity
four to five meters
it will be obscured according to the
plan but obscuring does not solve all
privacy concerns
in fact this window is completely
necessary the plan shows there are
several other windows in the room
the design is against spd4 neither
obscure glazing or above eye level
positioning are as satisfactory as a
design and layout
which avoids the need for such windows
that's a quote from spd4
loss of sunlight the high extension will
block sunlight into our garden for the
west
afternoon page six
parking robin road is small cul-de-sac
most families have at least two cars but
single garages
parking is a big problem with the loss
of one parking space
and a much larger sorry a much larger
household or even multiple households
multiple kitchen support ensuite rooms
the parking impact would be severe
again quoted from spp4 an extension that
results in the removal of a parking
space or garage
is likely to be refused unless car
parking replaced or provided
satisfactorily elsewhere
the replacement parking should be within
the curtains of the property
so in conclusion lots of garden space
and loss of sunshine are not considered
there is no need for the side windows by
design and would have devastating
effects on number seven's privacy
against sb4 2.15.5
three-story extension is overdominant to
the adjacent footpath
the extension is not visually appealing
and harmful to a street scene of a
central attractive space
and losing one parking space whilst
introducing much larger or multiple
households
would have a severe impact on parking
against spd4
2.12.1 thank you chairman
thank you miss callie um speaking
in favor of the application i think we
have um dr shazam
[Music]
yeah good evening just to let you know
you've got three minutes to speak
if you do run over time at all i'll just
politely request that you wrap up your
marks but
thanks for joining us this evening thank
you good evening councillors and chair
thanks for giving me time to represent
my case on this committee
i'm mr shazad kapar ent consultant at
countess of chester hospital
we are family of six including our 18
year old son and two daughters of 17 and
12 years living at six robin road for
last five years
this is currently a three bedroom
property since january 2019 my elderly
disabled mom is also living with us in
the same property
at the moment she is living in a
makeshift arrangement in the groud
living room
and uses the cloakroom which is quite
cumbersome for her
she fractured her hip unfortunately her
surgery was also unsuccessful
at the moment her ambulation is
restricted within the house with the
help of zimmer frame
we are looking after our mom 24 7.
we desperately need this rare extension
to create additional room with a
disabled ensuit for her on the ground
floor
rest of the extension above the ground
floor is to create separate
accommodation for our children who are
getting into adulthood
in these difficult times particularly
with increasing property prices
children will need parents support well
into their adult life
furthermore it will enable us to
continue living together as a family and
the children's grandmother will also get
their much needed support
from family under one roof my son may
well continue to live with us even if uh
if
after he gets married and continue
looking after his grandmother
i contacted two of my neighbors during
covet 19 lockdown and had a detailed
discussion regarding extension planning
one of them has already had a recent
extension
robin road is a cul-de-sac with 12
houses both detached and semi-detached
there is ample street parking space that
some residents routinely
park their cars on the street rather
than their driveways
one of the neighbors has established a
gym in the garage i've already
forwarded pictures of the street view to
all of the counselors
another concern raised is that the rear
extension will be protruding from the
rear build lines
the orientation of number four robin
road is tangential to number five
road projecting to in the rear our ear
extension will be in the same context
without appearing over dominant rather
it will create more similarity which has
also been mentioned in one of the
correspondence from the planning officer
there is a curve between number six and
seven robin road
due to this bend there is no concern of
loss of privacy from
privacy for number seven or eight which
is quite evident by looking
pictures already forward earlier to all
the counselors
our application has been in process for
several months we have made
several amendments and substantially
reduced the original plan
in an attempt to address neighbors
concern and the suggestion of planning
officer
our design is to best use of the
internal layout for a family of six
the extension is designed designed as
such to utilize as minimum space as
possible in the rear garden
and still keeping most of the area open
i hope the committee will review my rear
extension application sympathetically
and support planning officer's
recommendation thank you
thank you dr i can't see anyone having
indicated in the chat not sure if
anyone's happy turning over the
discussion
counselor thomas
thank you chair apologies for my late
arrival as well
i've visited robin road and i
do believe that this would be very
imposing on the very
small cul-de-sac um that is
the four five and six the
road finishes at the border of six and
goes to a smaller sort of like little
driveway leading up to seven
and to the rear coming out three meters
would take it extremely close to
uh the back fence of um number six
and i in my opinion from what i could
see despite
the the angle of the the row of houses
there
it would impact also on the view out of
a pretty flat bedroom window
from number five i think it was
and be very very imposing on back
gardens to both sides
of the property i cannot
see a way of supporting this application
in its present form because i do believe
it would be extremely imposing to the
local residents thank you chair
thank you councillor minis
thank you chair um i've looked at it
i've tried to
i think that the um if the owner has
obviously tried to work with the council
to try to come up with
what is um you know as as as acceptable
as possible
i'm not concerned about the loss of
parking um because the parking thing
i don't park my car on a garage so i
don't think that's really a concern
and just because you have extra space
for children and that doesn't
necessarily mean you need
another car um i've
got what i was going to say is i was i
wanted to hear about from others
what they thought about how the impacts
on neighboring's neighboring properties
so
and then i'll make my final decision i
think after
i hear the whole debate because i just
wanted to see what this thought about
how imposing it is to the neighbouring
properties but thank you very much
thank you councillor
thank you chair just pick up on the park
in which
councillor minis mentioned i don't think
this is a reason to
disagree with the officer recommendation
but i think and and the
the garage the carrying garage to the
property you know it looks looks quite
small so and and as kentucky says not
many people actually
park their cars in in their garages but
i do
think we need to consider this in
applications that we see because we've
had quite a few applications on
stanford brook now to of this sort of
nature that will reduce
off-road parking space and the the
estate clearly wasn't designed to have
on-road parking and
and you can see that as you go around
because where there is on-road parking
there are some little lay-bys that are
meant for the sort of terrace poses
but then you do see cars parked and
inevitably they're parked on the
pavement so
i don't think that's a planning matter
but i do think we just need to bear in
mind that you know designs like this
it is difficult to accommodate on road
parking i think a lot of time
um i think i've got concerns about the
application for this for the reasons
um councillor thomas said i think uh
looking it's a very you know it's a
small back garden as it is and
and this extension i think could be over
development of that plot and i think
it it you know it could have an impact
on the neighbours for the reasons
counselor thomas has already
as already described um
it's so we had a we had a similar
application to this on
the fur trees estates i think and
councillor holden came to
speak to the committee about that and
this is similar in some ways because
it's
the house is effectively a link detached
house so
the garages are joining each other and
this proposal is to convert that garage
to to living accommodation
um and that so i
i don't think that would be a permitted
development because i think the
permitted development rights were
probably removed when when the houses
were built
um looking at them although it doesn't
it doesn't really cover sort of
conversion
um so so it does so that that conversion
of the garage just does change the
character of the houses you know the
houses are built in that way that
you know a lot of the houses on the
estate have garages so to convert that
to living accommodation
does sort of change the character of the
street scene
i think um and the the last thing i
wanted to
was really a query actually which i
perhaps should have asked earlier which
is that a lot of the residents rely on
the
um stanford brook community trust
declaration and a few of them
attach an extract from that which has
some restrictions around
color of windows and alterations i
wasn't clear what the
status was of that whether it has any
weight you know a consideration i'm
assuming knox is not mentioned in the
report but it might be useful to
to clarify that i i think
probably i'm i'm leaning on the side of
um
of disagreeing with the office of
recommendation because i do think
looking at the plans it is over
development of the site
but i'll i'll wait and see what other
members have to say and uh before i make
my decision i think
chair thank you thank you um
thank you chair i'm gonna sound like an
echo account so hartley here um
um i've
this is a really difficult application i
really do think it is really really
difficult um
and i i just to start i would like if
officers could comment on the point
about the stanford
and brook community trust declaration
and it would just be appreciated just on
that but
to be honest on other the the other
items i have are
like i listened down to thomas and i
agree with every word he said
in terms of and i'm not probably quite
as strong in terms of opposing this
development i am
fearing on it um i really do think this
is a it is a big
big extension of this property and that
doesn't necessarily mean that we should
say no
but you don't need to look at it look at
the property and there's a couple of
things i think i think the fact is the
link detached
and the fact that it's not just on the
ground floor but it's on the first floor
and
and onto the second floor even and
when i visited the site at the thing
time because i went around the back
and the thing that i really noticed was
the garden side we're not talking about
and this is a stanford brook state
they are not big gardens so the impact
on your neighbours
of a similar size development where you
have a really large garden which some of
our older
older estates have is going to be less
than than this this is going to really
really dominate over
the small gardens that the neighbors
have and
i know there's a second point that i
have is on parking um
i i think it's fair to say i think
stanford brook state was not designed
for
though it's a very new estate it was not
designed for the number of cars that
people have on it
and probably the demographic that
possibly it is created in which
it's got a large numbers possibly of
families with teenagers
um but we're talking about a
five-bedroom house here
with one car parking space and it
doesn't
i mean if you visit it but just click on
google street view the road has
got next to no parking on it and
actually it's
a very odd corner in which that
effectively where you come off the road
and the
drive semi drive whatever you want to
call it for the for some of its
neighboring properties
um and whether it's this development or
other development
or all the neighbors it's gonna cause i
i can just see the problems which
exist on the stanford brook state you
know you know anyone who's driven around
it knows the
issues that that state has so i i really
am veering on both the
development of the site and parking
um for a five-bedroom house i think you
should have more parking spaces than
this
uh whether it be a garage or on a drive
um
i'll be interested in what other office
of other councils say but i'd also like
if
officers could talk about stanford
community trust declaration that'd be
really appreciated
thank you
thank you i don't know mr david you're
in a position to respond on this
issue of the community trust declaration
yes sir um in terms of the the stanford
book community trust declaration that
wouldn't carry any weight in
implying terms that's that's a purely
private matter
um so we can only assess it against the
the guidance and the policies with the
relevant plan um
not against stanford
community trust declaration thank you
and councillor bunting
thank you chairman sorry about that
plumber's getting myself off mute um
yes i'm going to agree with many of the
speakers that have spoken through
this is an awfully large development for
this size of plot
um particularly i think castle morgan
stated that a lot of these
modern houses have very small gardens
and that's the case here far smaller
than maybe
other properties of similar plants were
built and built earlier
and therefore these kinds of extensions
are going to have a far greater impact
essentially
what we're looking at here is to try and
make three households in one
uh as the applicant states he wants to
have his grandmother there he's
looking he's got grand children who are
gonna stay continuously after they're
married
essentially trying to extend this
property so that it will effectively
take three households within the one
household and it's not
the uh only i just think it's it's
having this council thomas
talking about the fact this is simply a
far too dominant on this site and it is
going to impact upon the neighbors
because they are very close together
they're not as widespread uh it was
widely spread out as baby
houses and then in an older housing
estate baby belts and as council morgan
was pointing out
the the parking in this as sizes as a
separate issue you're also horrific as
it is
especially given the immediate local
geography where you've got that
slightly awkward uh extension out to the
extended driveway that goes out to the
properties leading down to number six i
think it is
uh where you essentially any parking
outside
uh this property uh because we've only
got one one parking space for five
four five bed and if you've got say for
example the parents with a car it'd be
would be difficult to imagine one of the
two kids having a car i forget i have
several generations especially if
they're going to having to take their
grandmother to various locations as well
so you could easily imagine
more than one car that such a household
that will any parking outside this will
basically have to go out it won't be
able to go outside the house i think
somewhere else
and will cause yet more problems but i
think the main issue
is the is the shear is the size of it in
relation to the plot
i think it's simply trying to squeeze
too much into that one
that one part i i understand why he's
wanting to do this
i sympathize with the president for
wanting to do that but i also think that
this will have too much of an immunity
impact
not only in terms of the uh the sheer
dominance of it
also in terms of obviously i appreciate
the light comes from these
in the in the morning then what is the
morning light will be blocked from the
property to the side
um i like council thomas i just can't
support such a development in this
location if it was a larger plot
if i had a bit more land around the side
of it then then that might be
this might be doable but given the very
small constructed
uh size of this i don't think it is
going to be
and so um i say i'm
i wanted to make sure i wasn't being
overly harsh on this one and that's why
i held back
him to speak immediately but i'm leaning
towards us other counselors as i said
uh against officer recommendation which
i seem to think it's it's
too much for this very what is already a
very constricted site so a tight site
and will simply cause too many issues uh
thank you chairman
thank you uh councillor dr bart
thank you chairman i'm going to actually
take the counter view
and it's a really short report and if we
look at it it's short because the actual
uh concerns around residential immunity
are
are not mentioned i mean officers are
really satisfied about the impact
on number five number seven uh to the
rear of the property
onto the front of the property so i
think the officers are clearly
satisfied it hasn't raised any
significant discussion within
the um within the document and we know
that when these issues are particularly
marked
we get really really detailed documents
with lots of kind of explanations and
balances
and this makes it really clear that
there is nothing really of any concern
and officers obviously clearly satisfied
with that and i do feel
that if we refuse it given that the
applicant's likely to appeal and they
will win
so uh for my view i think that we should
well i'm going to be supporting the
application
the officers have presented a very clear
um
outline that there shouldn't be any
resident impact on residential immunity
and i'm
i'm really happy to support it thank you
chad
thank you councillor and council during
thanks chef i just wanted to um
ask a question really but um am i
am i right in thinking that the rear
extension only leaves
two meters to or 2.7 meters between the
end of the end of the extension to the
boundary
the garden boundary
so you want me to to respond to that now
yeah yeah if you can do that
um yeah the single story extension um
retains two meters um
the closest point to the rear boundary
obviously the the first floor extension
is set a meter further
away from that um uh
but yeah it i think the report does
recognize that it's relatively close
to the rear boundary yeah because i
think two meters
is just a little bit higher than i am um
and that does
i just wonder if um supplementary
guidance on
pg-1 does come into play and is taking
too much
garden space
a bit surprised that yeah can i
can i just comment further on on that
yeah i mean um
i think it's unlikely that um
appeal on the issue of loss of garden
space i've not seen
um an appeal um
that's been that's been uh upheld on
that
basis um so uh well
sorry dismissed on that basis um so i
i think that is unlikely to be um
you know a reason for refusal it would
be um that could be justified
really um obviously the impact in the
street scene
from river brook road is more of a
subjective issue
um but i think you've got to look at the
context outside of the site where
um the property is actually set for
slightly further away from river brook
road itself than the neighboring
properties at numbers
four and five um because of the footpath
cutting in
um from river brick road at that point
so yes it's closer to
the boundary with the footpath but the
actual boundary with the road there is
there's a little bit more gap outside
the site
yeah thanks for that i have to say
i agree with councillor morgan um this
is a very
very tricky application and
i'm still struggling with it i have to
say
it does eat up so much garden space and
i can't believe that it won't have
impact on on number number five
um yes i am struggling with it and i'm
kind of
inclined to agree with other councillors
that maybe
this is going a little bit too far
thanks chair
thank you mr day were you still looking
to um provide some further commentary on
the parking and immunity yeah if
i could please yeah um again in terms of
the parking issue
um i think um it needs to be recognized
that this is already a four bedroomed
house that's only it's only increasing
the number of bedrooms by one
um yes it's losing the parking space
within the garage um there is actually a
condition um
on the original permission which
restricts the use of the garage but it
restricts it to
um use as incidental to the um
the use of the drawing house so that
wouldn't necessarily retain it for
parking
it would actually restrict it to not
living accommodation but it could be
used
for example as a as a gym or um
you know some other non-main living room
not non-main living accommodation use um
so
it could be converted without the need
um
for uh planning permission um and again
in terms of
my experience of recent appeals i think
it's unlikely that the council would win
an appeal
on the basis of loss of parking um
in terms of the issue about amenity um
the the application does uh comply with
the council's spd4 guidelines in terms
of all
aspects of impact on amenities so again
um
uh you know i i'm i'm struggling to see
um exactly how a reason for refusal
would relate to um amenity but obviously
you know maybe members want to comment
more on that but obviously as i say i
appreciate that the the impact of the
extension in the street scene is
possibly more of a subjective issue
which
which maybe there's more leeway to
comment on
thank you thank you mr dave i am castle
in a minute
thank you chair and this is this this is
where the conundrum was it was over
parking was my lowest concern although i
have concerns about it but
it was my lowest concern my biggest
concern was
uh one of the bigger concerns but i
think visually it wouldn't look that way
was the um sort of terracing effect with
the garage use but then
because the first floor thing is not
happening then
obviously because that's been amended
and it's been that's come out then
it visually it wouldn't look like that
my
concern with the back was how close it
was
to neighboring properties number five
and that and to see actually was that
basically going to for amenity to
neighbors and
was that going to cause a problem and
that's the part where i was going or
sort of
teetering on the edge i can understand
why
the the owner wants to do wants to do
the conversion i can
i can appreciate wanting to look after
his mother i can understand
all the parts associated with it and i'm
so so struggling because i'm going
i feel like he's worked with the council
to try and come up with
something that is about as acceptable as
it can be and try and
whilst trying to get the the facts in
the parts in that he needs for his
family
but i do feel like it's probably trying
to cram in too much in a small spot
and i feel like it's probably too too
much
for a small area and
that's where that's where the conundrum
comes but i guess everybody else has
been having the same conundrum
um but i'll hear a bit more from
everyone else thank you
thank you councillor tommy okay
when i visited the site i went down the
cul-de-sac in my car
um i had to turn around and i'd reversed
towards where number seven is directly
outside the house there was a car parked
outside
uh number six as i arrived uh in the
process of turning around a prescription
was delivered to the house from a
pharmacy vehicle that just
left it in the middle of the road
because there was no other option to get
there so if a resident came down
he wouldn't have got into any of seven
eight or number nine
because of the the congestion so i think
parking does have to
take a little bit of um into account in
our decision
we're also well i respect mr day saying
that he's further away from the road the
rear extension than it would be for
numbers four or five the back of the
property there is about the only green i
mean i don't know the area that well but
there's the only green space
that i saw on my driving round the uh
the estate
where people can walk down a path or
onto the
like a a triangular patch of grass
um to the to the riverside road at the
back garden
so it's very very impacting on there as
well oh it looks so it goes very
very close to that if the garden was a
long
garden then maybe admit against against
it but you
it just seems too big and at the front
bringing the front forward would mean
that the they would virtually be
on the pathway with the porch so
it is the size i'm against so just just
to point out that i'm visiting it
there are amenities are impacted by
vehicular access to the site
thank you sir thank you councillor
stanley
uh thank you chair i deliberately left
my
um contributions towards the end of the
meeting because i just
really struggle with this one because
the
um i'll be briefly honest i don't like
the plans i don't like the
the way this will look but as with all
the decisions we make it's not
it's not about personal preference and
personal opinion it's about
whether um it stands in its
own merits in terms of planning
regulations
and i think this one does it stands on
its own merits in terms of
planning regulations the officers do a
good job going through the um
the office has done a good job going
through the uh the various reasons for
it
um and the thing which does swing you
for me is
it's only actually an increase in one
bedroom go from a four to a five
bedroom house so i think this is really
really difficult but i'm really minded
to um to go with the officer's
recommendation
to grant because i think if it goes to
appeal i think we'll lose
thanks chair thank you and counselor
thank you i just wanted to come back in
having heard from some other members
uh of the committee i mean um i i i
think
given given the advice we've had from mr
day i don't i don't think
parking can be a reason to refuse this
we can't speculate on how many how many
cars this this household is going to
have you know it's perfectly possible
for
a large household to have one car or no
cars and
you know the fact is although the design
although the
estate wasn't really designed for it it
is unrestricted parking
on the roads around the estate so um
i i don't think parking is is going to
be a valid ground to to
refuse really uh and i think mr days
covered that in his advice
and then i also think you know having
having just
looked together at the section on uh
residential immunity
the distances i think are all in
accordance with with spd4
so again i think in terms of residential
immunity they probably aren't
good grounds to to refuse this for us to
refuse this so
i still have concerns that the the
extent
of of of the extensions both the front
and and the back
and the conversion of the garage is is
over development and has an impact on
the street scene
i mean i think that's probably the only
the only reasonable ground to
to refuse in my view uh i'm not gonna
propose that because i'm
i'm still a little bit on the fence
about this this is this is really tricky
but i
i do think if members are sort of
considering disagreeing with the officer
recommendation that's that's the only
sort of ground i can see to
to consider to consider doing that
thank you chair
thank you counselor just to highlight
members
you know we have a quite a discussion on
this item now but there haven't actually
been
a motion moved um either for approval
or if you use all or default and
if i may help on that um just to try and
move things along for you
um i'm more than happy to propose i
think i've gone
on yeah proposed refusal on two grams
the
uh the fact that they are absolutely
building will be effectively dominant
and the impact on character of the
street scene
uh the two reasons i think would stand
up uh whilst i believe parking is going
to be an issue i
accept that it may not be sufficient to
uh
to form a third reason but on those two
reasons uh i accept what the applicant
is trying to
understand why they're trying to do it
but i think this is just unfortunately
the one place in which to do it
and so i can't support the application
on those two grounds thank you jeremy
council minister you just confirmed me
you second in that motion
yes i was going to say i'd absolutely
i'd be happy to second the refusal thank
you
are there any other members who would
like to speak
at this point now
can we just confirm the planning
department whether or not those reasons
are understood the the over
um the overbearing impact the
excessively dominant excessively
dominant
upon what understand the street scene
reason that's that's
straightforward but it has to be an
impact on something and that hasn't been
explained
i think the fact that basically the
building is going so far back towards
the edge of the plot and coming so far
forward i think it will be
visually very much intrusive there will
also i think be a degree of
overshadowing as a result of it
as well and i think there's some simple
visual
uh impact upon those people to who
living either side
in terms of the building i counselors
mean
own point out more or less to the back
back of the garden there's gonna be a
thin sliver of garden left at the back
of that house
uh and i think that will look um very
dominant from the from the neighbours
point of view especially for these
nearby gardens
and be very very visually intrusive
okay on on the neighbours um i would
just say at this point that the
proposals do comply with our guidance in
that respect but um
but understood what your reasons are
thank you
so no one else has indicated that they'd
like to speak
it has been proposed and seconded um
that this application being refused
contrary to officer recommendation
and move to the vote now and i'll just
move through members as you pick on my
screen
um counseling minutes um i vote to
refuse thank you um
counselor julian
it's really tough sorry um i don't
really agree with the street scene
uh refusal um so
i'm not sure if i
um i i i'll agree with the motion
to refuse thanks chair thank you
councillor um councillor bunting
support the motion to refuse chairman
thank you
councillor thomas
that's for the motion to refuse thank
you
thank you councillor hartley
thank you support the motion to refuse
thank you thank you
um councillor stanley uh both engaged
the motion to refuse thank you chair
cube
councillor morgan support the nation to
refuse chair
thank you council accordingly um
i oppose the motion to refuse
thank you councillor dr barkley i also
oppose
the motion to refuse thank you
[Music]
i shall be voting um against the motion
to refuse
i make that being fought against
and six in favor of the motion
as such that motions carried and the
application is refused
and the next item for consideration this
evening
is um the mugger at
the willows primary school which is on
page 85
of the committee report um come to the
minute i can see when you're getting
are you having to leave the meeting now
i'm having to leave anyway
because i have another meeting but i
wouldn't be able to be involved
in the willows primary um application
because my child goes there
but um enjoy the rest of the meeting
take care everybody
bye-bye bye um
so bellows primary school is going to be
introduced by
ms milner thank you chair i'll just
share my screen
so the application relates to the
willows primary school on victoria road
in templeley
the application proposes um a multi-use
games area um also known as a mooga
and and that would include a two meter
high
fence around the perimeter so this um
can you all see the map on the screen
okay good
um this shows in blue is is the location
now i'm not sure if you can see i'll try
and slightly zoom in but it has been
slightly enlarged as a
slight pink line around the edge and
that is following discussions with sport
england
sport england requested that it was
marginally increased
to meet their specification and
as such they they support the proposal
um the
moon has drawn um one objection but as
it is a council school
it is before councillors tonight and
there were two previous objections but
following dialogue with the case officer
they were withdrawn
and the objection relates to the hours
of use the local resident was concerned
that
they did not want to see the movie used
outside of school hours
however it will be used in line with the
remainder of the school site which is
also used by the community
and those hours are nine til seven
monday to friday and ten till
seven on a saturday um
like i said in line with with the
current use of the school site
um whilst um we appreciate the concerns
of the local resident
as this is not going to be um floodlit
and we don't consider that it would
increase the
impact and sufficiently to warrant
refusal and we are satisfied that the
site can accommodate the proposal
therefore subject to the conditions
in your um application in your report
we do recommend approval and so
just to clarify myself i said ten till
seven on a saturday it's ten till five
on a saturday
thank you thank you
um i don't think there are any uh
speakers to this item
um as such i'll counsel the bunting
and see you've indicated you'd like to
contribute yes thank you chairman be
very quick with this one um
from a very difficult application of
time before to a fairly
straightforward decision at least for me
on this occasion i can see no real
reason why you wouldn't wish to grant
this application
it's simply a further improvement of the
school facilities
as the council officer has pointed out
this is simply the timings of the
operation
aligned with the existing sites and
existing use i
as there's no lighting i don't think
there's gonna as a council officer also
points out all that's all the things i
was gonna say
this look at engine as there's no
lighting involved
issues if he's exhausted after school on
this saturday
so i can see no real reason to refuse
this application and on that
basis i'm more than happy to propose
that we grant it thank you chairman
thank you and councillor dr berkley
a quick client to say i really welcome
the application i think it's great that
we're
increasing opportunities for children to
exercise
fun outside i mean the murder means that
um exercise can carry on when the
weather's not so good it doesn't get
muddy and slippy like
ross would do and we're really bothered
about children you know childhood
obesity it's really important we
encourage our children to get out play
exercise and more so than ever following
being indoors
with a covered pandemic so absolutely
welcome this and um can't wait for it to
be built
thank you chair thank you and
councillor hartley
thank you chair not much to add to the
previous two speakers uh
good to see that you know sport england
are happy with it can understand the
concern that
people have about developing uh playing
field space but this is a much more
usable space the school are gonna get
and um
you know i'd also sort of applaud the
school on
engaging well with local residents but
you know it's clear that the impact
on residents has been um completely
mitigated by the conditions
so yeah i'm happy to i don't know if
cancer bunting prepares but i'm happy to
second if he did so happy to second the
motion to approve
thank you thank you and councillor
thank you chair just very briefly really
just to support
the other speakers i think the fact that
it
is not having floodlights and
um the times of use i think are
acceptable and it will be a big
improvement
for the school facilities and for that
reason i support it
[Music]
thank you um i suspect committees are
probably going to be
in agreement um on this item
so anyone with a billion desire to speak
consciously has already been proposed
and seconded
at the application
okay well we'll proceed straight to the
vote then um
councillor jerome
thank you councillor bunting
that's in line with uh of the
recommendations
you councillor partly thank you chair i
agree with the officer's recommendation
to grant thank you
thank you councillor stanley uh thank
you chair very happy to
grant him lost a recommendation thank
you
councillor morgan
thank you chair to agree to grant in
line with officer recommendations
thank you councillor thomas very happy
to grant in line with officer
recommendation chair thank you thank you
councillor
for the office of the foundation chair
thank you
council accordingly support officer's
recommendation chair
thank you councillor dr barkley i
support officer recommendation to grant
chair
thank you and i shall also be voting in
line with officer recommendations grant
that application is approved unanimously
um next item for consideration this
evening is
43 furnace road in davey hume which is
on page 108 of the committee report
and before we hear from any
presentations
the item is going to be introduced by
instagram
yeah thank you chad um just getting the
slideshow uploaded yeah um so
there has been an update on this
application which has been circulated
to the committee and i'll come back to
that um
at the end of the presentation but the
application is reported to the planning
and development management committee uh
due to receiving more than six letters
of
support contrary to officer
recommendation um
the application site comprises a
two-story semi-detached dwelling house
um as you see on the photographs located
on the western side of furnace road
a residential street within daily hume
the dwelling has an attached garage to
the north side and a single story rear
outrigger
and hard stunning exists to the front of
the property davey hume primary school
is located to the rear
the proposal is for the direction of
two-story side extension
single-story front extension
single-story rear extension and loft
conversion with rear door extension this
would create an open plan kitchen at
ground floor
and in large third bedroom and study at
first floor and a fourth bedroom in the
loft
the key issue is the impact of the
proposed two-story side extension on the
immunity of number 132
canterbury road the distance between the
proposed side elevation gable wall and
the rear main helical room windows
of number 132 falls short of the 15
meter separation distance
set out within the guidelines of spd4
officers consider the first development
would result in undue overshadowing and
overbearing impact
um on the rear main habitable room
windows and rear amenity space of number
132
and it's therefore recommended that the
application is refused
however as i said an update has been
circulated um the applicant's request
that a very recent appeal decision
was brought to the committee's attention
which
we only received the appeal decision um
on the day of the committee last
week um uh they believe it to be
material to
the this application and officers agree
that the appeal decision is material
to the determination of this application
um the
that appeal was in relation to a
first-floor side extension at one
litchfield road
in davie hume um that application was
refused at the planning and development
management committee
in october 2020 on the grounds of
overbearing impact and visual intrusion
on the rear windows and rear gardens of
numbers 137 and 139 canterbury road
the appeal has been allowed and the
inspector concluded that the proposed
extension would not cause harm to the
living conditions
of the occupiers of 137 139 canterbury
road
um an acceptable outlook from the rear
of these properties in their rear
gardens would be maintained
sorry i'm quoting from the the
inspector's report accordingly the
proposal complies with policy l7 of the
traffic course strategy
which seeks to ensure that development
does not prejudice the immunity of
occupiers of adjacent properties
although the scheme would not fully
accord with the advice in the spd there
would be no conflict with the purpose
with its purpose which amongst other
matters seeks to
safeguard neighbours amenity the
distance between the gable and the main
rear elevations of number 137
139 in that application would be similar
to that proposing the current
application at 43
furnace road so the appeal decision at
one literfield road is a mature
consideration
whilst planning officers aware that
there have been other appeals relating
to similar distance between
main windows and side elevations that
have previously been dismissed
it's recognized that one litchfield road
is in close proximity to the application
site
and that the interface distances between
the proposed extension and the rear
extensions
on those neighboring properties at one
three seven and one three nine were
actually closer
in that case than in the current
application and there was no outbuilding
positions
between the extension of those
properties as in the current case
it's already already been recognized in
the report that there are some
mitigating circumstances in relation to
this current proposal
as set out in paragraph 18 of the main
report in relation to the position of
the neighbors single story outbuilding
and the fact that this extension will be
set one metre off the boundary
as well as the fact there are nine
letters of support um
so it's considered that the appeal
decision at one literal road is a
further factor
um that considered together with those
other material considerations
could justify the approval of the
application if members consider that it
carries significant weight so if the
committee is minded to grant permission
suggested conditions have been set out
in the update thank you chair
thank you mr day um i understand we have
isn't speaking in favor of the items
yep good evening mr keenan just to
clarify for you you've got
three minutes to speak and if you do
over time i'll just um gladly request
this
contribution thanks for joining us okay
thank you chair um good evening and
thank you for being
being given the opportunity to present
our application to the planning
committee
firstly to provide a bit of background
information my wife and i purchased our
house in july 2013.
fast forward almost eight years and our
circumstances have changed considerably
we now have two young children who
attend the adjacent primary school
furthermore due to covid my wife and i
now work from home and this is going to
continue for a long time into the future
as a family we need more space to meet
our changing needs however we want to
remain in the neighborhood we call home
with the neighbours we know and call our
friends there's been a lot of activity
today regarding application
and i've had to redraft this speech at
the last minute the update paper from
the officer states that the appeal at
one litchfield road is material to the
determination of our application
one litchfield road is 100 meters away
from ours and on the same alignment
its gable wall will form the boundary
with no offset there is no outbuilding
forming a buffer
the separation distances will be
significantly below our proposals
indeed the appeal planning office that
made the following highly instructive
comments
although the scheme were not fully
accorded with the advice in the spd
there will be no conflict with its
purpose which amongst other matters
seeks to safeguard neighbors amenity
despite all this the case officer is
still recommending refusal
although i have correspondence with them
stating it would be reasonable for the
committee to approve our application
whatever the rationale for the case
officer's confusing stance it is clear
from the body of evidence that their
rigid interpretation of sbd4 cannot be
justified
the initial planning report states that
our proposals will cause no harm to the
character or visual appearance of the
street scene
despite this the report then states that
our proposed side extension
would be significantly below the council
separation distances
or have an undue overbearing an
overshadowing impact on the rear windows
and garden of number 132
with an emphasis on the concerns of
hypothetical future residents
from our perspective we are 10 letters
of support six of which are from close
neighbors plus council the dylan
we do not have one single objection
notwithstanding the material impacts of
the litchfield road decision
our proposals do not represent a
significant shortfall when viewed in
both wider and local contexts
within just one third of a mile there
are 13 properties with the same
alignment as ours with shorter
separation distances
four of which are sub 10 meters on
furnace road alone there are six
properties which fall follow the
separation distance data in sbd4
with regard to the argument our
extension will have an undue overbearing
and overshadowing impact
please note that the council is not
undertaking the shadowing assessment to
support this view
however our neighbour at 132 who has
lived in the property for five years and
knows the property best
has written in support of our proposals
and has stated they will not materially
alter the existing relationship with our
residential amenity
furthermore the built relationship with
132 is a key consideration
we have an integral garage then a side
path with the majority of our northern
boundary with 132 being formed of our
neighbor's largest attached pitch roof
garage
which is situated at the bottom of their
garden the finished floor level of this
garage is 0.3 meters higher than our
property
and the ridgeline of the garage roof is
a further 3.4 meters from the finished
law level
it is a substantial building and one
that dominates our neighbor's view from
the house
hence the description of it as being a
buffer between the two properties our
neighbor also states that our proposal
will not be overbearing in the slightest
i would suggest that our neighbor who
planning policy believes will be the
most impacted is the best judge of our
proposals
and significant weight should be
afforded to their views and support we
have the weighted appeal decision
no objections and only full local
support and i therefore respectfully ask
that the committee that's favorably on
this application and grant's planning
permission
thank you very much thank you mr keane
um councillor and stanley i can see that
you indicate i'd like to open the
stuff yeah thank you this is an
interesting one because
as i read the written officer's report i
kept waiting for the reason why we were
recommending that we
don't grant the approval and every every
paragraph because it complies with this
clause it complies with this um policy
complies with this rule until we get to
the bit about the
um impact on the immediacy of 132
canterbury road
and that's when i started to go right
okay the neighbors must have objected to
this then
because it's obviously impacted their
immediacy but of course their names
aren't objective
the names do not object to this the only
the the only reason that was there the
original objection was impact on 132 and
can't be real but those
people are happy i understand why there
could be some concern for future
residents but
that would be addressed when people
buying the house wouldn't if they
weren't happy they wouldn't buy the
house if the
if the um if the extent already existed
so i was already coming into the meeting
to speak against
the officer's recommendation the
additional representation we've seen
today as regards the appeal on one
litchfield
again says to me that it would be
perverse to refuse the application
from um uh from uh from the current
application
um so for all of those reasons i i'm
actually recording i
move now that we would um we would
we would recommend to grant this
against the officer's recommendation
thank you chair
thank you and councillor thomas
thank you again i've visited the site
and
although i respectfully see the the
reasons behind
the decision to refuse um
i do believe that they're slightly
insignificant in in terms of the garage
proximity the height of the garage and
the fact there are no windows on that
side
there'll be very little if any just
because i know which way the sun comes
in
uh impact on light into the back garden
and on the street itself on furnace road
there are
six uh houses that have similar
extensions that have closer proximity
to their next-door neighbors and a very
similar one
directly opposite number 43 so i i
cannot see why we would in light of
all the support locally why would i have
object to this
so i'm happy to second barry winston
lee's uh
motions thank you chad
thank you i'm councillor hunting
thank you chairman um well it's pretty
much all been said
uh in relation to this application by
the previous two speakers
um like the previous speakers i was
already coming into this meeting
struggling to agree with the officer
recommendation to uh refuse
and the additional representations from
inspectors simply
put the tin lid on it really so i'm not
going to
waste people's time by repeating that
which has already been the points have
already been made
and just say that i will be uh for the
reasons already stated by
previous speakers be supporting the uh
option to grant against officer
recommendation
thank you so much thank you and
councillor hartley
yeah i agree with my colleagues really
councillor winston they identified you
know the sole issue for the application
and it's less than the um
than the spd for recommended distances
but there are any recommendations and
and they shouldn't prohibit development
that's you know otherwise appropriate in
my view
the only i mean i can i can see that the
point of the uh you know the report that
that um
with the extension you know first full
level you are looking at
um you know a blank brick gable end
um might have been nice to break that up
with a window but then the window would
have to be
obscured laced anyway um but to be
honest the way the gable is at the
moment i think there's only two sort of
little windows in that third elevation
so i don't i think kensal would stand
these you know summed up the issue
and uh and rightly this sort of impact
and
together with that with the appeal
decision as well i think um
i think we would be on good grounds too
to uh
approve this against the officer
recommendation i think he would refuse
that we would probably be subject to a
similar appeal as in
one litchfield as well so yeah happy to
um
support the motion that's been moved
thank you
thank you council according to one yeah
yeah well come in and just to mention
the litchfield
one really because i think this the
reasons for
um rejecting the litchfield
um application were much stronger than
here
so the application um
i think we're on dodgy ground if we
reject it now
to be honest and i don't know where that
leaves us with other reject
other applications in future i'm a bit
worried
to be frank but actually this was always
going to be a borderline one
so i'm not going to lose any sleep over
allowing this one
but i do worry about the impact of that
litchfield application
thank you counselor it has been proposed
in a second did the
application be approved contrary to
officer recommendation i think
miss cauli could you clarify reasons
have been articulated sufficiently
yes happy with everything um i've heard
chairman in terms of
in terms of that and um can i just
confirm that members can just
can just nod that they're satisfied with
the conditions that we proposed in the
update report
yeah okay in which case uh quite happy
for you to proceed to the vote
well thank you um so i'll just move your
members as you appear on my screen
counselor gerard yeah i'll go against
officer recommendation
and grant some support
to grant this application thank you and
councillor bunting
for counting the application chairman
thank you councillor holloway
thank you chair yeah agreed a motion to
uh grant
contrary to recommendation thank you
thank you councillor in stanley
i create a motion to grant concrete
recommendations
thank
i'm happy to agree to the motion to
grant country to officer recommendations
jack
thank you councillor thomas
i agree with the motion to grant against
officer recommendations thank you
thank you council accordion there i
agree with the officer and agree with
the rejection of officers
recommendations
thanks uh for granting of the up
did the application check thank you
um councilman dr barclay i um
don't support the officers
recommendation to refuse and support
granting
thank you thank you i shall also be
voting
um as per the motion to approve contrary
to also recommendations the
application is uh granted unanimously
i think um the remaining
items of business on the agenda relate
to
some stopping upholders and gender items
seven
eight nine
ten and a lot in that thing um
i understand that they're going to be
introduced by ms hendren from
highway authority i think
hello yes um i don't know can you see
my oh there we go
yeah there's no presentation um it's the
the stopping off orders are actually
associated with a hybrid planning
permission
uh which has already been granted for a
her
sorry oh well valley housing association
development
in sale west um the
number is 100 206 hyb
20 and the stopping off orders just
comprise
small parcels of adopted highway
um part of footway bit of a car park
some open space and a small section of
carriageway
and the applicant needs the
these sections stopped up to allow the
development to go ahead
um some of these areas would actually
end up having houses built on them
um others will be um utilized um
for private immunity areas
so we would like to ask mr chairman and
the committee
um that they raised no objections to the
stopping up orders
as they're described in each of the
schedules
although they're presented as one it
will need a vote
per order
thank you ms hendren councillor bunting
he'd like to speak to the answers
very very briefly i'm obviously well
aware of this
redevelopment as it's as it's in my ward
these are entirely necessary as the
officer has stated they uh
simply there to provide to facilitate
the applications already on food
and i'm more than happy to uh so the
only to the one at a time i don't if you
want to propose them in second for each
one separately
to propose that we vote all for
but uh no objection be raised thank you
chairman
thank you and councillor morgan thank
you chair really quick i'm happy to
second
council of huntington's proposal okay um
so on a general item
seven which is the first stopping
reporter um
can i just confirm counselors bunting
and morgan are you happy proposing and
seconding is that what you were
indicating for that yeah happy job
um so no other members indicated they'd
like to speak to the items which has
just been proceeded straight to the vote
been proposing second did the no
objection be raised to a general item
seven stopping
and councillor jerome yeah i agree with
jeff i support the uh thank you
councillor bunting
happy to raise no objection thank you
councilman stanley
uh support the motion
thank you council thomas support the
motion chair
thank you council accordingly support
the motions chair
thank you for acting pull up the motions
chair
thank you councillor hartley sport
emotion chair thank you
thank you councillor dr barclay
oh sorry i just missed that and
counselor dr lee i support the motion
too thank you
thank you and uh i also raised no
objection
uh moved to agenda automate which is
again a stopping recorder
um no one's indicated that they've had
to speak cause anyone happy 2000 seconds
that no objection be raised happy to
propose chairman
thank you and happy to second chair
thank you
um we'll see to a vote counselor
thank you councillor hunting no
objection chairman
thank you councilman stanley motion
chair thank you councilman morgan
sport of ocean chat thank you councillor
thomas support the motion chair
thank you council recording mate support
the motion chair
thank you council acton draw the motion
chair
thank you councillor hartley support the
motion chair thank you
thank you counselor dr barclay bought
the motion chair too
thank you um i shall also
not be raising any objection and
something's right mate
now dealt with the gender item line
again is stopping off order
uh in relation to the same application i
can't see any
member indicating the right to speak to
it is it
proposed and seconded that no objection
be raised
propose no rejection chairman thank you
seconded
thank you um move to a vote
cancellation i support the motion chair
thank you
councillor bunting no objection chairman
thank you
councillor win stanley what's the motion
chair thank you councillor morgan
sport motion chair thank you councillor
thomas
mr thank you thank you council
accordingly
part of martian chair thank you council
actor
all the motion chair thank you
councillor hartley
uh no objection chair thank you thank
you councillor dr berkley
put the motion chair thank you
also not raise any objection
um agenda item 10 became
a stopping up order in relation to the
same application
i can't see any member indicating that
they'd like to speak um
is it proposed on the second did that no
objection be raised
no objection sharon back in the chair
thank you
um move to the vote counselor
motion chair thank you councillor
bunting
no objection challenge thank you
councillor stanley
motion chat thank you council morgan
scott the motion chair thank you thomas
no jason j thank you thank you council
accordingly
supporting the motion chair thank you
councillor
call the motion chair thank you council
hartley
uh sport emotion chair thank you thank
you councillor dr berkley
thank you i also support the motion that
no objection be raised
um last agenda item 11
again stopping the border and the
recommendation is that no rejection be
very easy to
ask if that is proposed in second leg
suppose no objection chairman
thank you seconded thank you
and move to the vote
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you uh councillor thomas
support the motion chair thank you
council accordingly
support the motion chair thank you
council acting for the motion chair
thank you
council hardly i support the motion
chair
okay thank you counselor doctor
what the motion chad thank you
i also support the motion that no
objection be raised
and gender item 11 is approved
paul doesn't have gender item 12 i can't
find my agenda though
um if anyone's got their agenda in front
of them
yeah it's chair it's uh it's another
stopping up order uh
yeah epsom avenue
the recommendation be that no objection
is raised
yes sorry that's right okay um
any members happy to propose in a second
to that effect propose no objection
chairman
seconded
[Music]
thank you counselor calling me partner
motion chair
thank you counselor acting for the
motion chair
thank you counsellor harley
support motion chair thank you thank you
councillor dr bartley
what the motion chair thank you i shall
also be supporting the motion that the
objection be raised
okay i think that's um this
the meet uh the business of the meeting
now uh
or completed um i've got my
agenda
recording